more on this now let's bring in former
ambassador ambassador to the united
nations nikki haley
ambassador welcome thank you for being
here there's so much to talk to you
about we're going to start off with the
border because this brand new interview
with kamala harris she was sitting down
with lester holt in guatemala
and he asked her just very frankly why
she has
not yet 76 days in charge of the border
crisis
gone to the southern border here was the
exchange
at some point you know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
ted cruz says she laughed it off
why will she not commit to a date and
time to visit the southern border
you know sandra this is embarrassing i
don't know what the problem is clearly
she's fearful but
kamla harris was given one job one job
and that was to deal with the border and
any leader knows
you can't fix what you can't see she
hasn't been on the ground she hasn't
talked to border patrol
she doesn't know what is happening there
so she says she wants to go to the root
cause and then she brings up europe
no one has given her the job of europe
she's got the job of the border and i
appreciate that she's going to guatemala
i appreciate she's going to mexico you
know why
because both of those leaders said that
the biden administration is the reason
that they're having all these problems
at the border
this is the same woman that literally
tweeted out
um come one come all we're open for
everyone i mean
all you have to do is look at that and
so now she's going to say do not come
you know what says do not come when you
show up at the border
and you really have actions speak louder
than words i don't know what her fear is
of the border but clearly she has one
and i don't know what biden's fear of
the border is but he has one
what i will call it is flat out denial
they think that if they don't go it
won't be real
it's very real speaking of denial
when it comes to this report that found
it plausible that covet 19
leaked from the wuhan lab ambassador i
want to get your thoughts on where we
are
with finding out the origins of covid
19.
considering that and we had mike pompeo
former secretary of state on this
program yesterday
he said there were some some in the
state department that that considered it
not pc to even consider this
wuhan lab leak theory and that he was
poo poo'd
every time he brought it up so how
confident are you
with this new investigation 90 days
biden's looking into this
that will learn anything more and that
it'll even be made public
well first of all this is should not be
the question of did this happen in a lab
did it happen in a wet market
my answer is prove to me it did not
happen in the lab
prove to us the american people prove to
the world where 3.7 million people died
that it didn't happen in the lab if i
were biden
i would send an american team to china
to the wuhan lab that's what president
trump did with me he sent me to the iaea
to ask direct questions about the iran
deal and i came back with direct answers
these are bioweapons this is serious
it has been way too long we need a team
to
show up we can't trust the world health
organization we can't trust
china to tell us what's happened they
have covered up and 3.7 million people
have died i don't care what happened in
the past
all i care is what happens now and that
means send a team to china
go to that lab find out if the world is
protected find
out what china knew when they knew it
find out what the world health
organization's involvement wasn't
and find out if america funded any of it
this should all happen
yesterday we've got to quit stalling on
this china needs to be held accountable
as a result you're calling out u.s
corporations that are going to be major
sponsors of the upcoming olympics
in china in your piece on
foxbusiness.com you say u.s corporations
need to shed their china hypocrisy
practice what they preach to americans
companies are free to operate overseas
you say including in china
but ceos should be more self-aware it's
outrageous you say
and embarrassing for them to
self-righteously talk about social
justice in america while staying quiet
when it comes to communist china's total
injustice
that's not woke it's just plain wrong
you write
so why do you feel compelled to call out
these u.s
corporations that continue to do
business within with china
and some of them supporters sponsors of
the upcoming olympics there
i am very passionate about the fact that
we should boycott the chinese olympics
we shouldn't boycott it alone we should
get our allies to boycott with it
we should get a coalition that has
already done something australia has
already asked for an investigation in
china and covet
canada's already asked to boycott the
olympic japan has already given itself a
stimulus to become less dependent on
china
india is ready and willing get a
coalition together what we are looking
at is a bunch of american companies
that are making money off of china you
know what they can do that
but guess what you can't turn around and
cry social ju
injustice you can't sit there and
condemn our georgia
voting accountability bill all while
you're supporting a
country that has wiped out freedoms in
hong kong has given
daily threats to taiwan is responsible
for 3.7 million
deaths is committing crimes of genocide
terrible crimes against women and
children and they're going to go
and over half of the sponsors of the
beijing olympics
are american then they're going to turn
around and say that we've got the
problem
i think they need to show us where their
money is i think they need to show us
why they're going to sit there and
criticize america and prop up china when
they've done all of this i think it's
embarrassing i think it's hypocritical
and i think the american public needs to
see it for what it is i want to turn
your attention now to this upcoming
geneva summit where uh vladimir putin
joe biden will be sitting down
uh we're told we'll have a face-to-face
meeting we'll see if that happens we'll
see
what sort of pressure the president puts
on vladimir putin
i go back to your own words july 2018
ambassador talking about vladimir putin
this is christian broadcasting network
we don't trust russia you said
we don't trust putin we never will do
you support
the president president biden sitting
down with vladimir putin
do you feel he's capable of being strong
enough or do you believe he intends to
be
with putin in this meeting you know i'll
always support
any of our american leaders meeting with
leaders of another country especially
when they went and
hijacked the you know or or you know
broke into the colonial pipeline
did this with a meat processing plant
but the thing is
biden's making sure that he gets a warm
reception because he went ahead and
allowed for nordstrom 2 which is
an unbelievable move you have turned
around and given russia the biggest gift
they could have ever
asked for you have literally stabbed
ukraine in the back
because otherwise oil had to go through
ukraine before it got anywhere else
and you've weakened our european allies
by allowing this to happen
it's unthinkable that he did this and
the only reason he would give a pass to
nordstrom the only reason he's no longer
sanctioning companies
that are producing the nordstrom
pipeline it's because he wants a welcome
reception from putin that's not being
tough on putin that's wanting to make
friends
we don't ever need to make friends with
russia they will never be our friend
those are strong words ambassador i
always finish by asking your ambitions
for 2024 having you respond to all of
that i'm sure
people at home are wondering as well
will you be running for president
i don't think i have to make that
decision yet but i can tell you we're
going to make sure we win a lot of house
senate and governor's races
in 21 and 22. we're getting to work
ambassador i really appreciate your time
today thank you